hello and welcome to the video LP for my
album this machine poems noobs this
album has a lot of songs on it you can
click on any of those songs over there
and you can go and listen to those songs
on youtube you can stream those songs
all day and all night for free you can
do whatever you want as long as you have
a connection to YouTube and the great
thing is you can also share those songs
you can put them on your tumblr you can
tweet them you can even share them on
your web log it is fun it is easy and
it's a free way to enjoy my music but if
you do enjoy my music you are welcome to
buy the album if you haven't already
it's available at dftba.com or also on
itunes also if you would like to listen
to the album as it was designed to be
listened to you can just click on this
play button and you'll be linked to a
YouTube playlist that will play the
whole friggin out before you and you can
clean your office which is what I need
to do right now while listening to good
music you don't even want to see what it
looks like behind this so I'm going to
shut up now and let you listen to the
music
[Music]
until your eyes
JPD mtv dftba dftb dftb there
to be a baby
DVDs
DBT
Oh
[Music]
I mean when we say
TV DVD
jeez
[Music]